the uber driver said to me he goes uh
he goes you know portland
is
has the most
strip clubs per capita
[Applause]
of any place
in the united states and i was like oh i
was like yeah
which part of me being with my
son and daughter made you want to say
that out loud
[Music]
what he said to me he goes you know the
best steak in town
hey at acropolis right is that he's gone
hey guess where i'm not eating food
yo and i'm going to tell you this right
now and every guy in here will know what
i'm talking about when i say this
i'm not eating at a strip club
and if i if you were going to say can
you use one word to describe a strip
club
the word i would use and every dude in
here knows what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about
is sticky
yeah you know when you walk in that club
and it's like
yeah yo every strip club is sticky
and it's not sticky because it's so
clean you know what i mean
and on top of that guess what
the cook at the strip club
yo look if i'm a chef
i'm not going to be like you know where
i want to work
so i i don't trust where that dude's
been with his hands
but more importantly
look i drove by a strip club i'm not
going into a strip club that has a
[ __ ] bike rack out in front of it
that looks so weird
i don't know why i was like
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]